okay this question has an easy bit in a
hard bed so here's the easy bit find the
monthly rate at the end of the two years
a lot of people ask me like what is what
is respectively mean respectively just
means in in that order and like one at a
time ok so one of the year's her rate
increases four and a half percent the
other year 5.1 okay we have the order so
that means four and a half first and
then 5.1 so to work out her monthly rate
can you see what I've done over here
right do you notice I didn't multiply by
a four point five percent I x 1 and then
the four point five percent why did I do
that for ok so if I had multiplied by
this what you're going to get is the
increase but not what she's actually
paying ok so this is kind of like what
was happening over here oops I lost it
over here in the compound interest
formula right that's where that one
that's why the one is there ok tell you
will give me the total value in the same
way I want to work out well what's her
total ray so I have the one there and i
also have it there so that's just
calculator work ok now for this next bit
we could have a long discussion about it
sorry to join us on yeah
okay so yeah sure so yeah sure so you
would probably so I did ask to hold on
the questions before so we'll just I'll
make this quick because i doing I do
want to answer questions just not now um
and I told you what this accurate it
means hilaryford tropical ignore
subsequent era so the idea is okay maybe
you got the right answer and then you
did some extra stuff and sometimes will
say that's cool you demonstrated what we
wanted you to demonstrate so I'm just
gonna politely pretend but all the other
stuff is not there I will ignore such
error okay now in this case I want you
to have a think right if you is the
marker now I rhetorical question don't
give me the answer I'll give you what
the actual answers in a second if you as
the Marcos saw a student and they wrote
this I don't know what it is like 100
and something under whatever it is okay
if you as the Marcos saw this rhetoric
question would you be inclined to ignore
that error or to say no I'm I'm gonna
actually do dr. mark for this just think
about it for a second now as a marker
looking at the way this question is
phrased I would not ignore that era and
I'll tell you why okay look at what the
question is asking look at what the
question is asking and look at how the
question is phrased when I have a look
at this there's a few different things
that are being assessed I mean clearly
ok can you multiply numbers really
actually that's not the real issue
because your calculator does that the
other question is like well what is the
question asking for and it clearly asks
to something that requires
interpretation do you know what the
monthly rate is can you look at the
wording of the question and say okay I
don't need to do any multiplication or
division that is the monthly rate so
therefore this this is out of place okay
it shows actually I don't understand
what that rate is earlier or I didn't
understand but I just execute it
incorrectly okay so in a case like this
I wouldn't ignore subsequent error but
sets a thing like on another question in
a different context I'm I'm okay but I
hope that makes sense for this okay now
let me give my
rationale for why Michaels getting
shafted okay um here's what sneaky about
this if you and this is an
interpretation question okay if i zoom
back out for a second right if you
answered part a let me get some of this
messy stuff out the way if you answered
part a for Michael instead of Meegan
okay you're going to get the same number
you're going to get the 1317 dollars and
ninety-five cents okay which is where
the trick lies okay so do you think okay
well after at the end of the two years
therefore they've paid the same out
there for neither of them pays more okay
now here's the reason why Michael
actually does look carefully there are
two years two years and the fact that
the respective thing means something
here is important because Michael it's
the 5.1 percent increase first and then
the four and a half do you see you can
actually go ahead you can crunch these
numbers i calculate these myself if you
did it year by year in the first year
clearly Michael pays more because his
has increased by more I mean not by much
about point-six percent it's not
negligible okay so you can see that's
the number you get out if you just do
the first years increase by the second
year their differences balance out but
that doesn't overcome the fact that
Megan is actually paid less for that
whole first year okay so even though
these amounts whoopsie-daisy these
amounts end up the same you have to pay
attention to the fact that that happened
to and that a whole 12 months michael
has been paying more does that make
sense okay that's a tricky question last
one what this required was for you to UM
this is why I gave you the formula data
sheet by the way mathematics driving
it's been a little while since you
looked at depreciation looks just like
the compound interest formula right
because the same kind of principle so
hopefully you saw okay this is the
formula i need to use maybe you needed
to
maybe the hot pot that was hard was to
recognize that the foreman and data
sheet it tells you what all of those
things are tells you what s and V naught
and r and n are representing but you've
got it what does what a salvage value
mean um salvage is about when you've got
something that's left behind okay like
salvaging a wreck is the way I always
remembered it so the salvage value is
this smaller number it's what it goes to
okay you can quickly work out by the way
if you go through this and you're like
oh out here you're going to get a
negative number if you try and swap the
numbers around okay so that's kind of
another clue that something may have
gone wrong but that's the process I went
through so I hope you're working make
sense